well you had something happen I believe
that's a writer's worst nightmare and
that is a script of yours was stolen
yeah I had a script stolen it was I have
two scenarios that you can say the word
stolen but the one that really I think
affected me deeply was I trusted people
that wanted me to write and that was 19
this was my first like hire for a film
like a film scripted I'm being hired to
write and I worked with people that I
really trusted and they didn't do the
wrong thing but they didn't protect me
to make sure the wrong thing didn't
happen or even ask me questions to make
sure I was thinking of it and the film
they told me originally they were like
well this is not really where we want to
go we'll circle back you know maybe a
year from now because we're gonna go
with another idea and I said okay no
problem I enjoyed the experience I got
to write a film's group start to finish
and just kind of wait it and then I saw
the film it was a maybe about two or
three years later and it was a little
different but it was like okay I wrote
that line you know one of those moments
so I think it was a horrible experience
but I can't say I'm glad it happened but
a lot of goodness came out of it it
caused me to be so much more prudent and
so much more watchful and wise which is
great for a personal use but then also
being someone on the other end now
hiring writers and so forth and even
something I'm working on right now in
pre-production it's like I want to
educate every young writer because it's
something that no one's gonna I can't
say no one but there aren't many people
that are not going to want to use you
for your gift and that's a good thing
but you got to make sure they're using
you in a way that you're comfortable
being used so it's like it's fine
your gifts are here to be used and shown
so don't feel like oh they're using me
that's fine
but just put limits and boundaries on
that and that comes in with legal so
most of these young writers most of them
unless they got into a place where they
kind of shot up to the top where they
can have an agent and a lawyer and this
and that somebody watching out for them
they have no clue what paperwork needs
to be put in place and how that
paperwork needs to be worded to where
they're protected and because of what I
went through I researched that and I
didn't just research it like now I know
but I also always bounced off a lawyer
it's even when I'm giving advice I'm
like hey this guy's and what this is
does this clause mean this because
that's what I'm thinking so just being
very very watchful of it and also I'm
like super protective of writers like
it's like oh like it's like a mama bear
thing that comes out and a project I'm
working on right now the provider just
like called me just a couple days ago
like I just want to thank you like you
have been there for me every step of the
way you weren't even on the project
really yet this is like way before
pre-production this is just like
conversations and he was like I just
felt so safe and I couldn't have had a
better compliment then that the writer
that was around me felt safe because I
experienced the other way around so I
want to make sure that anyone in my
presence writers produce whatever it is
they feel safe and they feel that they
can trust like I did but then also get
the outcome that their trust actually
mattered and it was the right person to
trust and I never want to like hurt that
in someone that's like something that
I'm very mindful of and I don't think
there's there's an opportunity for us to
make bad decisions like every person has
that saying like maybe greed or whatever
the thing is that you see great people
fall when you have already experienced
what great people do to when they like
what they can do in power but you've
been on the other end of that when you
get some power you're gonna be more
mindful of how you treat people so I can
say that that experience of having a
strip a script stolen makes me a better
leader makes me a better producer makes
me a better writer makes me a better
person because I know these people
weren't bad people but they saw an
opportunity they're like well we don't
have to really pay her anymore we don't
have to really bring her in she's not
owed any points let's just go
don't even tell her like that can happen
when you have greed so I I don't look at
them I don't think of them as horrible
people I think of them as people that
are come to greed or because they could
you know we all want a sense of power
and they use it the wrong way so it
helps me use it in the right way more
often and with more intention what what
are some tips aside from having legal
look over a contract or even emails what
are some signs like a red flag that a
young writer should be aware of
I think signs of red flags for
young writers or any writer is people
asking you for things that you one don't
understand or two you didn't agree with
already so it's like usually how it
happens they kind of sneak it in there
it's like okay we have an agreement and
then it's like hey can you also do
such-and-such and young writers
especially they're like I can't wait to
do these things so they just do it don't
do it be okay or you start writing it
start working on it but don't tell them
don't say okay don't say oh absolutely
just say oh sure just have whoever call
me so we can just change it change the
contract you can do it in such a way
that doesn't seem like you're checking
them just make it seem like you're just
being helpful like oh you I'll take care
of it I can talk to whoever let me know
or do I need to sign something else exit
innocent question like that and I tell
you those people will adjust their
movements just say oh great sure do I
need to sign something different and
they say no that will be the next red
flag that it's not only that they maybe
we're negligent
they're probably trying to take
advantage of you because you do have to
sign something there needs to be an
adjustment and if they're not willing to
do that you don't need to be in the
situation or say in a situation because
we know we got to be in places sometime
where okay be amongst the snakes but
like the Bible says be a dove like we
don't need to act like a snake so we
need to know how the snakes move be
there and just keep very watch and care
on what you are doing and presenting to
them so they're like hey where's that
such-and-such oh yeah I have it pretty
much ready I just need whatever paper I
need to sign so bring it up later you
want the fight them you'll have to argue
with them you don't have to III see
another thing and young writers are like
I read that such and such or my friend
said such and such and it's like now
you're just going to come off as a jerk
and that person might have been innocent
in the situation so just come from an
acquisitive place and then record that
response
I'm not saying record or a scenario or
like have a look like a phone reporter
or whatever but after they responded
write it down so you can then think
about it later and then talk it over
with a friend of course it's great to
talk a little with someone in the
industry but even just hearing yourself
out loud talk to someone helps you kind
of understand where someone's moving so
write it down exactly what they said
send a text to yourself I do notes all
day all phone calls you when I'm sitting
on a call I'm writing down certain
moments in the call just to kind of okay
what just happened here so I think just
being mindful of like requests
and then seeing just seeing not
responding but seeing how they respond
to you pushing back on their requests in
any capacity and that will be a telltale
sign that this probably is gonna be a
situation where people are not going to
protect you so you can stay in it but
just be ready to protect yourself or
bring someone else in to protect you
I like that let's take the scenario
where the person tries to turn it around
on you and make it almost seem like
you're the one that's the problem so
let's suppose they say well I only
operate with a handshake and I go on
good faith like that and I would hope
you would trust me
well now that makes you feel like oh wow
now I look like I'm mistrustful so you
would almost want to prove to them okay
oh that's why I yell we'll do that out
of you when they try to turn it around
has happened to a lot of people and make
it seem like it doesn't need to be
changed or initialed or noted I think
first first understand that your trust
has to be rooted in truth so Trust is
built you don't owe anyone it I just
have that stance
I don't know Trust to anyone they have
to build it and I have to build it for
them they don't have to trust me to go
right and do my job don't act like hey
I'm a writer I've done such and such
either you have to come in humility but
Trust has to be earned now you don't
have to tell them that but have that
stance so so let's say someone says
something like that where it's well I
operate on a handshake and I hope you
would trust me absolutely I hope so too
so I'm going to start writing on this
and just expect that whenever you're
ready you're going to give me a piece of
paper or you're gonna put this in
writing and then I can deliver it it's
just for me and it's so many people out
here that you can't trust right like
kind of connect with them right and then
they're like look what crazy person
wouldn't be like no trust everyone give
them truth that's why if your trust is
rooted and true that you stay in a place
of truth you won't come off as combative
or difficult just stay in place of truth
there's so many people all here right
yeah I get it yeah so for me I'm gonna
start moving sure but I just can't
deliver anything until that piece of
paper and only because I've seen so many
crazy things happen and I don't think
that would be you like you know you have
to put those things in there to
alleviate you know something that could
end up being conflict but still Trust
has to be earned so let them earn it and
also have that same stance on you if
you're not making deadlines if you're
you know not giving them proofs of
things and
the type of examples that they wanted
providing them with enough people that
they can call and say yeah they're great
whatever the case may be don't be
offended when they're not trusting you
either so you have to understand trust
you're not out it and you don't know it
to anyone but still operate in the space
of by building it or for building it I'm
going to just kind of confront them with
truth not in confrontation in a negative
way so I would say that's the way to
deal with it just kind of respond very
graciously but also then bring them a
truth that they can't disagree with
which is it's a lot of crazy things
happening here right and then go from
there
you